so we're asked which function has the
greater y-intercept
so the y-intercept is the y-coordinate
when x is equal to zero so f of zero
when x is equal to zero the function is
equal to let's see f of 0 is going to be
equal to 0 minus 0 plus 4 is going to be
equal to 4. so this function right over
here it has a y-intercept of 4. so it
would intersect the
y-axis right over there while the
function that we're comparing it to g of
x we're looking at its graph y is equal
to g of x its y intercept is right over
here at y is equal to 3. so which
function has a greater y
well it's going to be f of x f of x has
a greater y-intercept than g of x does
let's do a few more of these where we're
comparing different functions one of
them that's this in a visual has a
visual depiction one of them where we're
just given the equation how many roots
do the functions have in common
well g of x we can see it their roots
the roots are x equals negative 1 and x
is equal to 2. so at these two functions
at most are going to have two roots in
common because this g of x only has two
roots there's a couple of ways we could
tackle it we could just try to find f's
roots or we could plug in either one of
these values and see if it makes the
function equal to a zero
i'll do the first way i'll try to factor
this so let's see what two numbers if i
add them i get one because that's the
coefficient here or implicitly there and
if i take their product i get negative
6. well they're going to have to have
different signs since their product is
negative so let's see negative 3
and positive 2. no they actually the
other way around because it's positive
1. so positive 3 and negative 2. so this
is equal to x plus 3
times x minus 2.
so f of x is going to have zeros when x
is equal to
negative 3
x is equal to negative 3
or x is equal to 2. these are the two
zeros if x is equal to negative three
this this expression becomes zero zero
times anything is zero if x equals two
this expression becomes zero and zero
times anything is zero so f of negative
three is zero and f of two is zero these
are the zeros of that function so let's
see which of these are in common well
negative three is out here that's not
uncommon x equals two is in common so
they only have one common zero
right over there so how many or how many
roots do the functions have in common
one
all right
let's do one more of these
and they ask us do the functions have
the same concavity
and the way i think or one way to think
about concavity is whether it's opening
upwards or opening downwards
so
this is often viewed as concave upwards
and this is viewed as concave downwards
concave
concave downwards
and the key realization is well you know
if you just look at this blue if you
look at g of x right over here it is
concave downwards so the question is
would this be concave downwards or
upwards and the key here is the
coefficient on the second degree term on
the on the square x squared term
if the coefficient is positive you're
going to be concave upwards because as x
gets suitably far away from zero this
term is going to overpower everything
else and it's going to become positive
so as x gets
further and further away or not even
further away from zero as x gets further
and further away from the vertex as x
gets further and further away from the
vertex this term dominates everything
else and we get more and more positive
values
and so that's why if your coefficient is
positive you're going to have concave
upwards a concave upwards graph
and so if this is concave upwards this
one is clearly concave downwards they do
not have the same concavity so no if
this was negative 4x squared minus 108
then it would be concave downwards and
we would say yes anyway hopefully you
found that interesting